et on en parle avec vous Elena Volochine
journaliste spécialiste de la Russie
Elena bonjour pas de mobilisation
générale a annoncé comme beaucoup le
pensaient mais encore une justification
de cette opération spéciale en c'est
comme ça que l'appel Vladimir Poutine
auprès de l'opinion publique russe
finalement oui effectivement Vladimir
Poutine a de nouveau marqué cette
continuité qu'on voit de façon
permanente qui est qui va presque de soi
maintenant pour les Russes entre la
victoire contre les nazis en 45 et
celles qui est censée obtenir de nouveau
aujourd'hui dans sa lutte contre le
nazisme mondialisé comme comme le
présente Vladimir Poutine en 2022 donc
il a martelé toute une série de dogmes
qu'il répète sans arrêt il a eu des
messages cette fois aussi contre contre
l'Occident pour pour finalement
justifier cette décision difficile mais
l'absence de choix il présente toujours
comme d'ailleurs le faisait Staline à
l'époque cette cette
il est difficile comme comme la
signature en 1930-1939 par exemple par
Staline du pacte Molotov ri-bandtrop
aujourd'hui Vladimir Poutine cette
opération spéciale il la présente comme
un pas obligé pour défendre la Russie
qui soit disant aurait été menacé par le
rapprochement de l'OTAN de ses
frontières il a dit par exemple le temps
ne nous a pas entendu menace
inacceptable vous l'avez entendu
l'Occident préparait une invasion de
notre terre y compris la Crimée le
danger croisé de jour en jour et
finalement cette opération spéciale elle
était nécessaire elle était prise la
décision était prise à temps et c'était
la seule décision juste donc ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'on dur entendre les
Russes aujourd'hui qui finalement ont
entendu une version très théorique de
cette opération spéciale à aucun moment
Vladimir Poutine n'a de nouveau prononcé
le mot guerre nan a dit que la Russie on
n'avait pas l'impression dans les Russes
qui ont finalement très peu
d'informations
paradoxal parce que on est dans cette
grande parade militaire dans cette
grande démonstration de la victoire qui
est une fête qui est vraiment une fête
aux yeux des Russes mais on n'a pas les
je n'avais pas la notion y compris en
attendant ce discours et en voyant cette
parade qu'aujourd'hui leur pays est en
guerre que leur pays est dans le rôle de
l'agresseur qu'il bombarde le pays
voisin pour restaurer des frontières
dans une visée impérialiste non cette
opération est purement présentée
Vladimir Poutine la redit dans ce
discours comme la lutte de la Russie de
notre grand peuple du peuple uni
soviétique sous-entendant par là que les
peuples russes et ukrainiens devaient
s'unifier et on voit d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui tous ces drapeaux de l'Union
soviétique d'un pays qui n'existe plus
finalement et que donc ce peuple devait
s'unifier dans la lutte contre des nazis
soutenus par par les Occidentaux merci
beaucoup Elena Volochine